what's up reject nation we're moving on
now to one division
trailer number two minute and 27 seconds
damn i really thought it would be longer
but let's get into it it's right around
the corner let's do it
[Music]
so what's a single gal like you doing
rattling around this big house
well i assure you i'm married to a man a
human one
oh naughty
we just don't know what to expect look
at how striking the visuals are
so colorful
god it even looks like a map painting in
the background
monica
oh interesting
interesting
hey you said random you saw jimmy boo
hey cat daddy's
[Music]
yeah dude
we will be doing reactions to this
series so keep a lookout for that we'll
be putting it up here on the youtubes
quite excited all right so we gotta see
some jimmy woo in there we gotta see
some cat dannings darcy in there monica
rambo
the vibe that i'm really getting from
the wanda vision show
is that it's gonna start off where
they're kind of trapped in this
alternate reality that i really do think
it's mephisto
i think that's how you say it mephisto
because even in this trailer the whole
thing with agatha first i thought
it might have been agatha who is doing
some of this uh
mind manipulation to wanda in the
trailer you do get this glimpse
of the jimmy character randall park and
then you do get a glimpse of darcy
and monica rambo does show up at the
doorstep
and i feel like they probably sent her
in to see what the hell is going on to
investigate or whatever
is happening outside of wanda's head
must be having some type of weird effect
and then that's why they're probably
setting this and that's probably why the
shield
subsidiary group star is in there and
then once you go in there it just starts
messing with your mind and then
something like is the first half of this
series just going to be them going
what the hell's going on what the hell
is going on is that that's the first
half
what a twilight zone what's happening
what's happening you know is the first
half going to be all
positive and peachy and then it starts
getting dark you know i'm really
wondering how it's going to progress
as a series but as far as what we're
getting here the visuals look dynamite
this looks creepy it looks unsettling
feel like you got a lot of these cool
little horror elements and i feel like
there's going to be something really
major around the corner
with its finale that's going to really
make a big difference in the marvel
cinematic universe
yeah i feel like once it really reveals
the true nature of whatever strange
state
everyone has been kept in you know here
yeah cause i it does seem like everyone
is affected by it in their own way
including wanda and vision
maybe they are the keys to breaking
through it or whatever but yeah i love
this anthology-esque vibe they've got
going with the different tones and eras
and i love anything that can sucker you
in with like
here's something peachy and fun but
that's really sinister underneath and
from all the posters they've been
putting out with these little motifs of
like the wallpaper is peeling it's not
what it
appears i think like there's a lot of
surprises i store
i feel like this is gonna end in a
heartbreaking manner
this is gonna have a dark ending it's
gonna feel heartbreaking because
it looks like when they're getting you
wrapped up in the loving elements of it
that are mirroring some of the
television shows i think we're really
gonna get absorbed into all that
and i can't wait to see like a more
detailed shot by shot breakdown of this
because there is just
so much imagery in here in the briefest
glimpses
well that's i i gotta imagine they're
probably gonna break our hearts with
vision because there were moments during
this trailer with him where i was like
oh man
he's back it looks so cool he's lazy i
mean really here there's even one point
where it looks like wanda is grabbing
the mindstone
so i imagine that there's going to be
some devastating things that happen but
also
colliding with this like military
operation trying to
get involved too because it looks like
it poses this alternate reality and the
way into there is through wanda's mind
in some way
she's the gate we'll see guys we'll see
we got what
loki miss marvel and what ifs to go
let's keep it going guys let's keep this
train rolling
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell we'll catch you guys
soon
hit that like button while you're at it
[Music]
you